[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen es ist
dass dieser seinen thunfisch ein
wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns hier
auf jeden fall unserer kleinen süss
micro fällt meine lieben freunde ich ja
das ist nice das kann ich noch direkt
mal holen denn das wird auch das thema
für die heutige episode sein ich würde
sagen wir hören uns war vorher erstmal
ganz kurzen wirksamen polizisten
das heißt dass du bist ein loch auf
türkisch eine liebe freunde ihr sitzt
bereits mit titel eingeblendete rest in
peace
die die kuh schon vor vielen folgen weil
ich die wolle brauchte ja ich habe jetzt
gerade nur drei stück allerdings habe
ich hier vorne in der kiste er noch
einiges und zwar habe ich jetzt
insgesamt 33 braune wolle und das reicht
auf jeden fall für den kopf was sich ja
vor ein paar folge schon gesagt habe
dass ich den dort hinten hin bauen
möchte wir haben hier fordert den
schafskopf und dann kommt da neben der
kuh kopf dafür müssen wir die heutige
besucher auf jeden fall die obere
schicht sand abbauen das ist allerdings
nicht das einzige was wir vor meine
lieben freunde denn ich muss mir auch
noch eine menge quartz aus dem netz
holen ich muss was weil ich gute frage
eigentlich habe ich mein letztes in den
kommentaren gesehen ich habe hier vorne
mein haus gehabt da oben ein bett
drinnen läuft trotzdem immer hinten zum
baumhaus
ja das stimmt allerdings habe ich mir
gerade schon missverständlicherweise
sandstein reingepackt ich benötige
nämlich normalen sein denn ihr seht
schon wenn ich mir dann um kohle heißt
es immer nichts gutes denn ich muss mir
eine menge neuer beton machen von eine
ganz ganz ganz ganz großer teil netz ich
berate sachen für den kopf zusammen
sammeln
[Musik]
so ich bin fertig ist gar nicht so lang
gedauert wie ich dachte in anderthalb
minuten weil ich schon eine menge sachen
wirklich hatte die sache ist allerdings
dass wir lange nicht mehr mit diesem
bruder hier geredet haben perfekt warum
ich allerdings ganz kurz auch anhalte
ist dein ganz einfach der grund warum
ihre auch schon hier und zweitgerät denn
wir müssen ja immer noch mit unserem
bibliothekar ein wenig handeln wasser
den rückstoß und verbrennung das
brauchen wir beides nicht wir brauchen
auch keine laternen
ich muss allerdings ein bisschen
hochleveln weil ich mir ich bin auch
keine bücher gar nicht gesagt haben so
weil ich ein wenig ihn hochleveln der
tat er das frech ich bin frech wie hast
du nicht aber wir haben jetzt zwölf
laternen die wir allesamt nicht
benötigen die sagt das allerdings dass
ich ihn ja ein bisschen hochleveln muss
denn wir brauchen immer noch unser
reparatur buch wir benötigen unser ich
weiß gar nicht mehr was wir noch alles
benötigen auf jeden fall kriegen wir das
nur durchs trading mit ihm jedoch seht
ihr schon ich befinde mich hier auf der
insel muss ja immer ganz kurz die
sandfläche abtragen und währenddessen
ich das tue muss ich ganz kurz sagen
freunde das ist die erste folge
minecraft mit luca die ich innerhalb von
eineinhalb wochen aufnehmen
die letzten videos waren alle wissen
nämlich vorne was abgebaut die letzten
vier teams waren alle vorproduziert da
ich in köln war mit freunden mal wieder
in meiner heimatstadt und ich habe es
vermisst ich habe es vermisst ich
demnächst auf jeden fall häufiger wieder
in köln sein und es fühlt sich ein
bisschen komisch wenn ich wieder am
tisch zu sitzen ich habe auch meine
haare ein bisschen wieder hoffentlich
gleichzeitig ihr da ja auch andere
ansicht ein bisschen besser schneiden
lassen die seiten und hinten
jedoch habe ich das hier vorne jetzt
erst mal als abgetragene dass eine volle
drei dings frei und bauen jetzt hier
vorne den kopf hin dafür gehen wir hier
3 in die höhe dann gehen wir 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 das passt auch perfekt hier nochmal
in die höhe und nehmen nun unsere weise
wurde die wir nur für diesen bereich
benötigen zack zack dazwischen packen
wir jetzt den
und von unserer kuhn da merke ich direkt
dass ich doch noch genügend sachen dabei
hoffe ich idiot
vielleicht hat jemand zu wenig grauem
beton mitgenommen man merkt auf jeden
fall das nicht lengerich aufgenommen
habe fast allerdings extrem geil ist
dass man diese diese kuh kopf
tatsächlich direkt vom weg aus schon
sieht dahinter das geil da unser weg ja
direkt gerade durch geht müssten wir
diesen kopf dann wahrscheinlich auch
schon aus unserer kisten für hinten raus
erkennen können jedoch da ziehe ich hier
jetzt erst mal unseren grauem beton dann
sind wir hier meinen gerüst habe ich
jetzt natürlich wieder nicht mit dabei
da völlig allerdings ein bisschen sand
ii mit vom staat
es gibt nämlich ganz kurz hoch müssen
jetzt hier vorne eine reihe braunen
volle draufsetzen und dann hier aus
schwarzem beton und weißem beton dann
die augen ihr seht schon das ist ja
alles eine kombination aus wolle und
beton denn ich finde bei so augen da
machen wolle keinen sinn da nämlich die
beton und hier oder genauso wie wir der
schnauze da finde ich hier noch sowohl
in ordnung aber hierfür finde ich dann
beton ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen besser
das passt dann irgendwie alles finde ich
ein bisschen besser und wolle nehmen wir
für den ganzen körper
da gehen wir nämlich hier sofort zack
zack und hier dann noch eine viererreihe
obendrauf nämlich ein 23 und da fehlt
mir jetzt auch wieder ein
das kann nicht sein ich ein ziel gesetzt
wir schauen gleich mal nicht auf jeden
fall erstmal noch die braune wolle drauf
damit sie mir insgesamt hier so
hochgehen maxi wiederum sind auch wieder
keinen sinn habe ich mich jetzt so
verbaut
da müssen wir wieder abbauen
jetzt regnet als wenn mir der minecraft
gott sagen würden mensch du hast dich
richtig scheiße gebaut
[Musik]
nicht aufgenommen
die sache ist allerdings dass wir ja
hier vorne immer noch unser bett stehen
haben und damit können
ach das ist gar kein gewitter das was
das bett hin das ist die völlig neben
der spur
dass piraten ist jetzt richtig wild was
er können wir eigentlich mal ist sie was
wir machen
ich stelle jetzt einfach mal ein paar
laternen drauf das ding ist halt
wirklich dass ich so viele laternen
einfach mit dem villiger getradet habe
so dass ich hier überhaupt nicht weiß
wohin mit den ganzen teilen und da
setzen wir einfach mal hier vorne setzt
man mal eine hin dann könnte man mal
hier irgendwie eine hinsetzen dann hier
vielleicht noch eine dann laufen wir
hier übersetzt du vielleicht hier noch
eine hin
hier und da noch wir vorne dran und dann
natürlich auch selbst auf die andere
seite ihr wisst dass sie mir jetzt mal
nicht von der anderen von unserer insel
aber dann wissen wir zumindest es
leuchtet auf beiden seiten und iranische
frau liegt wenn ihr durch einen
dschungel fahren oder so wahrscheinlich
piratenschiff durch den dschungel schon
geil aus da hinten außer der kuckuck
deshalb bisschen am arsch
oh mein gott ich schwimme hier gerade
durch so was gerade nachts geworden und
der delfin auf einmal alter jagt mir ein
kompletten strecke nein aber gut ich
habe auf jeden fall mit dabei das heißt
wir können schlafen und können uns jetzt
gleich und wieder tag ist darum kümmern
dass wir unseren kopf da vernünftig
hinsetzen hier von der seite sieht er
auf jeden fall vernünftig aus aber das
sagt oben das ist völlig am arsch also
keine ahnung was mir dabei gedacht habt
ihr am lg sprung um die ecke perfekt
klappt wenn man ganz kurze an der seite
hoch und jetzt kann ich mich auf eben
kurzem mit mir kurz hoch bauen und hier
schauen wir mal was er falsch gemacht ja
hier ist falsch
da sollte nämlich eigentlich der braune
wollen aber das heißt ja dass ich auch
eine braune rolle zu wenig habe meine
die krieger von da oben dann gott es tut
mir so leid freunde sowie für die neben
der spur ich bin es geht so viel gerade
ab in meinem leben irgendwie ich weiß
auch nicht warum also der hier kommen
oben hin jetzt gehe ich ganz gut wieder
runter ohne natürlich schaden zu nehmen
bau ganz kurz die eben den sand ab sagt
zack zack zack zack und jetzt plötzlich
braune wolle hier drin und dann müsste
es theoretisch passen also ich werde
jetzt mal direkt von der anderen insel
aus angucken wenn irgendwas falschen
mutter muss ja wieder zurückschwimmen
aber ich bin mir sicher dass das passt
wenn ihm ein attest welt hat das so auch
funktioniert von daher meine lieben
freunde
rest in peace liebe es gibt auch geil
auf mit dem piratenschiff dahinten jetzt
mit den laternen finde ich
[Musik]
macht ihr mal da vorne
das sieht auf jeden fall sehr sehr geil
aus also an der stelle nochmal rest in
peace liebe bleibt für immer in unseren
herzen
mir wurde auch die kommentare
geschrieben dass ich ja bei der camping
insel da hinten sieht man es von hier
nehme man kann sich richtig erkennen
hier sieht man so ein bisschen das zelt
glaube ich dass ich dort die teile den
packen kann das essen für meine teile
hört sich ganz bald schon dass ich dort
dahinten essen
[Musik]
wir lassen ihnen wieder sterben einfach
nur schön verbrennen so einfach als
bestrafung
mir wurde viel geschrieben dass ich da
hinten ja einfach das essen für die
tiere reinpacken kann die sache ist
allerdings dass ich das sieht auch sehr
geil passieren ich tue so als hätte ich
hier wochenlang nicht aufgenommen bin
gerade wieder in meiner welt und feiere
alles aber ich mag es auch hier extrem
die sache ist allerdings dass ich in der
nächsten folge euch auch auf jeden fall
das ist ja eine wanderung in die
leserate das alles ein bisschen aus mit
der insel aber das sieht sehr gerne was
mit dem kopf da wir die sehr stolz was
ich sagen wollte war dass ich euch in
der nächsten folge auf jeden fall ein
bisschen ja schon mal genauer sagen kann
was mit aus diesem projekt hier wird
sage ich mal also jetzt nicht dass
irgendwer schon aus dem zehnten stock
wegspringen sich jetzt denkt scheiße wir
beendet und so ich habe einfach ein
bisschen gedanken gemacht ihr wisst auf
youtube nicht immer jemand gewesen der
das gemacht hat bock hat und auch wenn
minecraft gerade irgendwie gefühlt ja
schon 1000 jahre alt ist hatte ich bock
drauf habe es gemacht und ich habe auf
jeden fall ein plan wie das ganze hier
weitergehen wird mit dem projekt dauernd
das werde ich euch in der nächsten oder
übernächsten folge sagen ich muss noch
ein bisschen was planen bzw
wir überlegen wie es genau machen bevor
ich verbinde nicht sage und dann werden
ja alle irgendwie direkt das paar wollte
ich grad sagen du bist immer noch ein
huhn zu kanski welcher anderer rund
hatten konto flugzeug ist keine hund die
sache ist nun allerdings dass ich
erstmal meine glück drei diamant
spitzhacke reparieren muss denn meine
lieben freunde wir haben keine kohle
also was heißt keine cola wir haben
wahrscheinlich nicht genügend level ich
dachte das 24 streichen weil ja nicht
komplett am arsch das allerdings muss
ich dann wahrscheinlich diese hier
reparieren das kann ich mal eben kurz
machen was kosten nur drei erfahrungen
bzw
können wir dann noch mal ganz kurz
gucken dass ich mir
vielleicht eine eisen spitzhacke oder so
verzaubern mit glück drei wir müssen
wirklich den bibliothekar hochleveln
sodass der uns vernünftige bücher geben
kann
der ist sogar schon hoch gelobt wird
glaube ich mir vor die tür zugemacht
die ja den haben wir ja schon hoch
gelevelt da kann ich mal ganz kurz eben
schauen ob wir bei dem sonst vielleicht
ein glück drei oder vielleicht sogar
auch nur glück zwei buch abstauben
können das war wirklich sehr sehr sehr
sehr wild er schild glaube ich hier
vorne im gebäude drin ja und er hat
rückstoß verbrennung stärke 3 auch sehr
sehr wild und sonst nur noch eine uhr
stärke 3 sehr sehr geil aber wir
brauchen halt leider wirklich
wir brauchen leider wirklich das dingens
gebrauchen leider wirklich glück 3 oder
sonst auch das reparatur buch ich muss
mir musste mir jetzt gerade von ihm noch
mal ein paar laternen holen so dass wir
einfach ein bisschen hochleveln er ist
gerade auf meister stufe glaube ich ich
glaube das größte was es gibt es experte
oder er war expert und das größte ist
meister ich hab keine ahnung genau die
es wagte packe ich mal ganz kurz wieder
reine die diamanten auch mal besser das
kann schnell und wir schauen jetzt doch
mal eben ganz kurz ob wir das hier
hinten machen können mit dem glück drei
buch das wäre wirklich sehr sehr wild
wenn unser zauberte schon einmal endlich
einen vernünftigen verzauberung spruch
geben könnte also du hier rein du hier
rein wir haben haltbarkeit zwei hier ist
effizienz 4
das kriegen wir halt leider nicht hier
mit den leveln das ist ein bisschen doof
aber gut da müssen wir leider die
spitzhacke so lange brauchen ab brauchen
bis sie ja fast kaputt gegangen ist und
dann müssen wir auf die glück ein
spitzhacke zu greifen ihr seht doch
schon meiner linken hand das totem der
unsterblichkeit denn meine lieben
freunde das wollen wir auch in die
kommentare geschrieben luca benutzt das
doch mal häufiger du hast immer an der
linken
entweder irgendwelche fackeln
wie pilz angel habe ich vergessen ich
habe jetzt auf jeden fall eine menge
quarz gefahr meine lieben freunde und da
ich wirklich mehr als eine
dreiviertelstunde lang im never war hab
ich mir gedacht ich kenne keine normale
tempels ein mit musik denn ich finde ihr
habt ihr wieder fit und möchte schon
gepostet ich habe nicht mal gesagt hör
auf diese bewusste ist gefährlich wenn
corona so also jetzt ganz schnell zu
einem witz freunde und zwar warum gehen
ameisen nicht in die kirche
weil die insekten sind so leute ich hab
die sandra mal wieder ganz kurz die
vorne geparkt danke dass ich auf der
reifen durfte werde ich auch nicht also
freunde ich habe auf jeden fall ein zwei
drei einhalb stacks quad abgebaut die
sache ist allerdings dass wir für die
fertigstellung der strandhaus will
insgesamt 66 benötigen ihr seht
allerdings auch hier unten in meiner
leiste bereits dass die diamant
spitzhacke unsere glück drei diamant
spitzhacke fast am ende ist und ich
idiot hat natürlich nicht genügend aus
ist weil nicht macht wenn ich hier
ankomme ob es die echten als mit dem
kopf da hinten back to topic meine liebe
freunde ich habe natürlich nicht
genügend eisen mitgenommen um mir immer
schnell einen amboss zu kräften und ich
habe auch einfach nicht den amboss
mitgenommen in erster linie deswegen
muss ich immer ganz kurz noch mal zurück
gehe ich habe jetzt auch gar keine
diamanten dabei denn ich möchte mir die
diamant spitzhacke kurze mal reparieren
und das wirklich in dieser folge alle
schaffen
ich weiß dass das vielleicht ein
bisschen ambitioniert ist jetzt wieder
zurückzugehen in netter allerdings kann
ich jetzt ja auch schon meine nicht
vorhanden
kohle nehmen wir müssen auch demnächst
endlich mal wieder eine hürde ich kann
auf jeden fall schon mein ganzes
quartier einpacken das dann gleich ein
bisschen braten und euch dann nochmal
eine letzte teil des für heute in der
ich hoffentlich die letzten quartz
blogger abbauen werde
also folgende situation ich habe euch ja
gerade eine teil apps eingeblendet und
die sache ist dass ich deswegen unten in
die hölle gegangen bin in die hölle ich
bin unten gerade in meine höhle gegangen
nicht in die hölle
ganz kurz eine quote dazu ich hatte
damals mal activity mit meiner schwester
gespielt und sie musste das board
bärenhöhle darstellen also zeichnen oder
irgendwie so und die sache war dass sie
allerdings noch nicht richtig lesen
konnte und bären hölle gewesen
also genau den gleichen fehler gemacht
hat den ich gerade gesagt habe und da
hatten die bären in lava gemalt und dann
haben wir gesagt dass das bärenhöhle und
ich bärenhöhle war sie angefangen zu
weinen werden genau das gleiche auch mal
mit das hat mir hundehütte dann hat die
hundehütte gelesen hunde mit hüten
gemalt ist aber auch scheißegal ich
wollte auf jeden fall gerade sagen dass
ich schon seit ich habe eine menge zumal
gerade ausgegeben denn wir haben ein
namensschild bekommen von unserem
von der bibliothekarin sohn und jetzt
kann ich mit meinem namensschild oben
zum amboss gehen und das namensschild
jetzt einfach schonen die shawn das
schaf und damit können jetzt rechtsklick
auf uns einig das ist wieder umbenennen
ich muss das ding ja dem schwein geben
okay das funktioniert das schwein heißt
ja papa mich idioten man man merkt dass
ich schon länger aufgenommen habe ich
muss das ding jetzt auf jeden fall mal
vergeben weil wir die ganze zeit wieder
umgedreht werden ich weiß nicht wo der
gerade herumdümpelt ob er immer noch da
unten am wasserfall irgendwie schild ich
weiß gar nicht warum da also vier kommen
dass münchen kommt nicht weg liegt sogar
schon also das müssen auf jeden fall
demnächst einmal wiederholen
die sache ist dass ich ja das schwein
mal umdrehen wollte das läuft ja immer
noch falsch herum verkehrt herum
ich weiß allerdings nicht wo die sache
ist allerdings was habt ihr vielleicht
auch aha da ist ja der bruder
die sache ist das habt ihr
wahrscheinlich auch schon der teilhabe
es gerade gesehen ich habe es probiert
mit einem ich nehme auch mal dass die
eben mit dann kann ich das schwein
mitnehmen ich habe es probiert meine
eisenheim eine diamant spitzhacke zu
verzaubern bzw zu reparieren mit dem
amboss das hat allerdings nicht geklappt
das ist noch immer zu teuer
ich habe 30 level und 60 diamanten wie
viel soll ich denn noch ausgeben um das
ding zu reparieren ich weiß dass eine
glück drei diamant spitze extrem op ist
die sache ist allerdings das erste mal
am korb kein problem hat auch lange
genug gedauert
das habe ich gerade gesagt ich hab sowas
gehasst im kindergarten setzt sich
lore und fahrt zurück
die sache ist dass ich mir jetzt gerade
gedacht habe weil ich die diamant
spielzeit nicht richtig reparieren
konnte und weil ich jetzt auch schon
wieder bei einer halb schon auf neue
zeit bin ich war einfach 45 minuten im
netter quarz farm dass du das einfach in
der nächsten folge machen wir machen zu
beginn der nächsten folge mein gott als
ich darf nicht noch mehr tiere hier
töten
ich muss direkt mit der karotte zu
pepper hinlaufen dass er sich ein
bisschen besser fühlt ich werde auch
jetzt mal direkt weiter zunehmen damit
zum schiffchen gehen und das ein
bisschen kümmern also einmal weizen und
die karotten habe ich glaube ich in
einer kiste kräfte hinten allerdings
meine lieben freunde wie ich ja gerade
schon gesagt habe das werde ich auf
jeden fall in den nächsten episode
machen
mit dem quad fahren und mit der
fertigstellung der villa zumindest der
außenfassade also des rohbaus erstmal
für die ich hier ein weizen so und für
pepr hier vorne schnell eine karotte
zack dann bist du auf jeden fall auch
wieder ein bisschen geheult also die
andere karotte könnte ich endlich mal an
pflanzen nicht dass wir hier irgendwann
keine karten mehr haben davon hatte ich
meine meine freunde ich würde an der
stelle der heutigen episode minecraft
luca jetzt auch beenden
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen ich habe
eine menge gequatscht mein ganzer mund
ist fusselig friedlich ist falsche wort
ein ganzer mund ist trocken so dass
parteien schwertes mal noch immer noch
mein absoluter fällt diese ecke hier
wunderschön wenn es euch gefallen aber
die mit freundinnen einen daumen hoch
und ein video hier da abonniert main
kanal und klickt auf die glocke wenn ihr
neue videos nicht verpassen wollte denn
übermorgen kommt direkt die nächste
episode minecraft beluga online wie
bereits gesagt wir beenden die
strandhaus wieder zumindest den rohbau
und werden noch mal kurz in netter gehen
also schaltet auf jeden fall wieder ein
wir sehen uns ich habe ich die macht
eigentlich ein tag wie sie macht euch
einen schönen tag die folge geht um 20
uhr online
[Musik]